các bạn nghe gì không nhỉ
à à
ê ê
cho tất cả các nhòm đang làm đồ ăn mát ạ
bổ
sung Hà còn mình có Nam Định là nếu mà
hôm nay không kịp với chắc phải thứ năm
nữa
anh nói chung là để dứt điểm tất cả nhóm
làm đồ ăn đã về Cái này các bạn sẽ phải
hiểu cái này là cái quan trọng nhất ạ
Cái này rất là quan trọng cho chồng việc
làm đồ án
cái này mà say không thể làm được đoán
bắt buộc phải phân tích cái này nữa cẩn
thận kỹ lưỡng
những thứ hát thì không quan trọng không
ạ
ừ ừ
cho Bây giờ thì đội các nhóm nào Chuẩn
bị nhóm nào mà có đầy đủ hoặc à đại diện
nhóm có đây rồi trình bày trước cũng
được à
a57 trình bày trước gì
Tải
game
một mình em thôi nhỉ Bạn kia có con chưa
Ừ
ok rồi nó cũng được Có gì bảo các bạn
xem lại thôi
kiểu đấy à
bộ phim sex
vợ anh anh thôi
ừ ừ
anh gọi
Anh karaoke
khách hàng vào gì
xe xe
ở điểm xuất phát của thời gian để đặt
cô
tham gia đình trình
khi bộ phim đã tạo ra được nhiều chị
Ừ
cái này nó đang bị sai so với cái hôm
hôm qua nếu mà em làm một khác nó sẽ bị
có vấn đề và là mã bến lặp lại
vì anh chưa hiểu cái bến ở trong cái
lịch trình lắm Anh thử giải thích hơn
nữa
là kia là một nửa hả em á nó nào đúng
không cái mã bến ở trong cái gì nhỉ
thì
em sẽ
ok ok
em có xe cố định theo lịch trình
ngày cố định theo Lịch trình hả
Ừ
cũng được
thì bây giờ dễ hình dung đi giả sử là
anh anh nha Anh muốn nhập lịch trình của
một xe từ Hà Nội đến Hải Phòng
có 5 chuyến trong ngày hôm nay sẽ ý
nghĩa là năm chuyển thì anh sẽ nhập và
những bản nào
À
mà bạn ấy sẽ lưu lại những việc gì
a
không điểm xuất phát là Hà Nội điểm đến
Hải Phòng đúng không thời gian đi Ví dụ
là từ 1 giờ 3 giờ
motor này thời gian đến là bao giờ này
Anh hello
Ừ rồi
nếu anh như thế này thì cùng là xe đấy
đúng không cùng lắp bây giờ tại cái Hà
Nội Hải Phòng 1 giờ đến 3 giờ ok Thế còn
lại tiếp tục tại ở Hà Nội đến Hải Phòng
cho đó thì 5 giờ đến bây giờ lại lặp lại
đúng không
anh lái xe lại lặp lại mấy cái thông tin
đấy
thời gian đi thời gian đến này là bao
gồm cả trong ngày còn lưu lại cả ngày
nữa nhỉ đúng không Chứ không phải là mỗi
giờ đúng không
Ừ ok
này thì ta lập lại cũng được không sao
không sao cho nó gọn cho chị gộp chung
một bà cũng được
anh ngồi ở đây em phải có khuyến mãi nữa
một mã trong ngực bảo để trình ấy mãi
lịch trình mà đúng không
ở Bến Tre
anh
ra được cái nào tôi bây sẽ giản là nó có
xe nối đến một xe của em có bao nhiêu
lịch trình nào
khi
u12a
em không Nếu mà kiểu này là một sai
nhiều lịch trình nữa
ở
Vienna trinh nữ lại mã xe không phải là
xe lưu lại mãi lịch trình
Ừ nếu có xe lưu lại mã được trình thì
một xe máy và một
em em đoạn này các bạn đang hơi bị loạn
rồi tới thể này Đây nhá
một xe của em có bao nhiêu lịch trình đó
lại mà theo em thì em định thi Kể một xe
của em thì đi từ điểm này đến chuyện kia
thôi cố định hay là Tề hôm nay đi máy
điểm kia hôm sau đi lại đi hiểm khác à
các clip nóng Nguyễn mã linh thế một xe
ở một lịch trình đúng không ạ
ê kê
ngoài giống kiểu xe khách kiểu nó cố
định truyền đúng không cố định tuyến nó
đúng không
em ở nhà một xe đấy một ngày có đi nhiều
chuyện không
anh
em xem nghiệp
nhưng mà vẫn là vẫn là lộ trình đấy thôi
đúng không Vẫn lộ trình phải đi qua
những nơi đúng không
i
m m một cái gì đó Ghi rõ ra nốt nốt tay
thì mình sẽ hình dung hơn ở nó phát vì
rõ bạn được
a&m HD anh anh bạn nhanh cho
Ừ anh phải màn hình cho nha
Bởi vì anh thấy là nhiều nhóm làm kiểu
này ra mỗi nhôm có thể làm thêm một tí
nhưng mà bây giờ để anh giải thích lại
một lần cho mấy bạn hiểu nhé
Anh
nhạc
đây thì rõ ràng là mình có một xe này
ở
ta có
khu du lịch sinh thái
à à
du
lịch trình Lịch trình nó khác là lộ
trình nhá lịch trình ở đây nó sẽ là ngày
này
từ
đến à Giờ đi
rồi đến ở ạ
anh ấy con cái vừa rồi em bảo là lộ
trình kiểu là như thế này cơ
phim hài
Tỉa hoài vệ sinh ra trước lộ trình này
là mã này điên đi này điểm đến này thấy
ví dụ là giờ sử Hà Nội Hải Phòng đúng
không Đây Thực ra là em
đi đái kiểu kiểu như thế nó sẽ nối sang
Nga để hiểu là xe này thì đi từ Hà Nội
đến Hải Phòng thôi Đấy là lịch trình
trong ngày hôm nay là sẽ còn mãi đây lại
đúng không
Hãy lịch trình
ở trong ngày hôm nay
ngày 11 xe thì đương nhiên là có nhiều
lịch trình trong ngày
anh đúng không
anh
em hiểu nhỉ
Ừ đấy thì đây là một lại nó là cái này
là một đầu nhá Anh xin lỗi nha
khi
sử có thật 23 xe cũng đi từ Hà Nội đến
Hải Phòng đúng không Tiếp theo là cái
này lại là nn một lịch trình có thể rõ
ràng người khác xe khác không thể đi vào
lịch trình này đúng không ạ ví dụ là
trong ngày mùng 1 từ 1 giờ đến 3 giờ tao
rất nhiều sai đi về không Rồi đấy đúng
chứ
em không tìm giờ đi tới đến sao đâu
ở điểm gì đến
anh
anh đi ngược lại à
bây giờ đi rồi đến nó phải khác chứ
Ừ
từ 1 giờ em ạ Từ 1A
Anh ở Face rồi đi từ Hải Phòng về Hà Nội
được chuyển chỗ khác mà ngon
vì vậy chị nhớ than ngon Ừ đúng
vì
được nói có hai đội trình là điểm đi là
kiểu nó bị ngược lại nữa ngon
11 sai nó sẽ không có một lộ trình
Ừ nếu mà đi
được đến này
đang ở
anh em nhé
khi bạn xóa ngay đấy ạ
ngày rồi đi rồi đến
ờ ờ
xe điện pin điểm đến này
giải quyết vấn đề nha Ờ
có một xe
hi hi
chú ý tưởng
cứ thử gõ gà ship cho dễ hình dung đi
Tí
nữa mình làm theo trường hợp kiểu này
nhé
chương
em có điểm đi điểm đến
ngày giờ đi chờ đến
được à Không bỏ qua ngày được Bây giờ đi
về đến thôi Giờ này bao gồm thời gian ra
thời gian đi
và thời gian đến
để xử đi qua đêm thì trong cùng ngày
không đúng
Hà
Nội này Hải Phòng này một rồi này bao
giờ này đi Hải Phòng này về lại Hà Nội
đúng không
Ừ từ bao giờ năm rồi Cả ý em thấy đúng
không
thường ra thường ước lượng thôi chứ nó
không chuẩn đâu
Ừ cái này ức lượng luôn
cũng không không hạt là đúng đâu
Ừ cái này kiểu gì thằng sinh tầm chục
phút
A Happy là nó xe xe không phải là tàu
tàu nó chuẩn hơn Trần giờ hơn xe có
nhiều vấn đề em nhờ người ta Kiểu gì
người ta cũng tính rồi ra giờ nửa tiếng
gọi như này chứ 4 giờ mày tao ngủ đi
6:00 ngay kiểu như này cơ sẽ cho chất
thả nó sẽ lôi ra Cấm 1 tiếng cho tài xế
nghỉ ngơi cũng
tắc đường thì còn gì đó không à
ờ ờ
Ok kiểu như thế này thì là xử lý có mã
như này
ý
tao nói thì từ đó vé
vé thì bản chất là
Ừ mình định Đợi tí nha du lịch sử Lý Hải
đúng không
anh gọi thì vé thì sẽ có mã lịch trình
này
anh
có mã và em sắp đi mã lực thì
chưa trẻ phải lại màn hình xem em làm
cái đoạn vé thì em sẽ làm nha à
khi
ở
chỗ chồng á số chỗ trống là gì nhỉ em
nhỉ
3000 mình sẽ phải nữa dù Maxwell rồi đến
dùng cốt để đến xem xe có báo chỗ chứ
không lưu lại phải yêu đấy
như Loại già thôi mà nói chuyện nhớ
chuẩn rồi
Ừ
đơn ra là của em mà
cái bản chất ở đây thì ở thực ra là cái
hóa đơn đấy nó sẽ chính là phải vé đấy
A
Gọi nhà mình mua thẳng có bạn mua bao
nhiêu vé ở trong cái hóa đơn đấy
Bóng Đá bản trước là mịn không chọn mình
không cần phải in vé cũng như mình không
không có chọn chỗ ngồi nên thành ra là
hóa đơn mình là có vé số bé trong đấy
rồi gọi là số đạt cho bao nhiêu người ấy
hiểu về thế em mình dùng không
anh
nghe ca cái hóa đơn bản chất là nó cái
hóa đơn nó và lỡ cả gọi như nào nhỉ
thường ấy thì em sẽ bạn một cái hóa đơn
với cho luôn một cái lịch trình
trường hợp ở đặt hai lịch trình cùng một
thời ơi Anh Nghĩa là chỉ có một lịch
trình ơi trứng chúng không
à
Hay là cứ hồi thì
anh cứ hồi thực ra nó rẻ hơn thế em sẽ
nốt thêm là khứ hồi nhau cái đấy tức là
chúng ta hơn
Ừ
ừ Nhưng nếu em bắt ra cũng được tách ra
được thế là sẽ có mã hóa đơn mãi lịch
trình
Ừ
hai đứa bé là phá trinh
nghĩa là bản chất là vé nó không nối
trực tiếp đến có lịch à Nó nó sẽ nối cả
hóa đơn Ý anh là thế
khi
đi xe đi xe máy bay đâu mà có vị trí của
gọi nhá Anh chưa thấy có trang web nào
đặt vé vé xe khách mà
Tàu nó còn khó cái vụ chọn được chỗ ngồi
ở
cùng lắm là chỉ có xác định ở ghế để cái
vip hay không thôi ghế giường nằm mãi
không thôi
em chứ ai trông chọn ghế ngồi ơi
hôm
ngoài
đi xe cao cấp nó có hẳn cái vé rõ ràng
nó khác Còn bây giờ thì nói thẳng là bảo
rồi Đang đi lời chừng khó người muốn lên
xe vẫn ở lên được thì cái vé nó không ý
nghĩa gì cả nước
á nhon
Ừ
lưu lại mã vé
khi mở về xem nhé
à à
Em
Ừ anh ăn chưa thấy cái Trang web nào cho
đặt chọn chỗ ngồi rồi
có người lại cùng lắm à Em sẽ tự lên rồi
Em tự nói là chỗ mình ngồi cạnh ai thôi
ở
chỗ mình đặt hai chỗ thì mình sẽ ngồi ở
đâu mới cãi nhau ấy
vì
toán khó nữa rồi vì mình sẽ phải lưu lại
cái sơ đồ phải cưng của xe nó sẽ phức
tạp hơn anh nghĩ bài toán đơn giản trước
thì á các bạn chưa cần phải làm một cái
phức tạp với Vội cứ phải giải quyết được
đầu tiên là vì sau ra được cái số số bé
thống kê cứ thử đủ kiểu nữa
nó sẽ khiến Mai Toàn nó phức tạp hơn
để giải quyết được cái cốt lõi là đặt
được vé xe đi đã gửi tình tiết
Anh quay quay quay lại với thực thể đi
thì ở đây Ở đây đang nghĩ nhá Nếu Như Em
vừa bảo là Đạt được khứ hồi đúng không
em mình cứ cho mình đặt vé trong một hóa
đơn mình phải đặt nhiều vé là nhiều lịch
trình đúng không ạ
ý
nghĩa là bao gồm được trình cả đi đến
ngày thậm chí lịch trình của hôm khác
cũng được Đi kiểu cho hết sản phẩm vào
giỏ hàng ấy tôi ở nút thanh toán hình
toán có thể đúng không ạ
chi phí hóa đơn nó sẽ có nhiều vé đúng
không ạ
anh em dưa hấu khứ hồi đến lẽ Người dưng
nước mờ em làm chưa nghĩ ra bị rồi Hậu
Không nhưng mà cái đấy cũng được làm gì
đó
nó sẽ là một hóa đơn cũng có thể làm
được nhiều về đi đúng không
em làm một vé thôi nhiên là có chứ có
một chương trình thôi chứ
Xin
Một Vé xổ bao nhiêu hóa đơn
Ừ
thằng vé sẽ ở trung gian nữa không hóa
đơn hàng được trình đúng không
Thế thì thằng bé nó sẽ lưu lại mã hóa
đơn và hóa đơn không cần phải lưu lại mã
về nữa chồng chứ
ở
chỗ nào
anh nói trung gian mà thằng vé trung
gian nữa hóa đơn với lịch trình kia đấy
sẽ mã hóa đơn
Ừ
ông không không có cột mã nữa bản chất
là nói thằng trung gian nó là nó là bảng
phụ Kiểu cái thế nó sẽ không có một mã
riêng của nó
Ừ
hai cái cục kia sẽ khỏi chỉ cho nó rồi
a a
nhân viên mãn khách hàng Thời gian đặt
tên người đặt ạ
ê kê tương đối rồi
ở
đây sinha bến địa chỉ rồi xe hãng nào
chỗ ngồi Ok tương đối đấy xem thử cơ sở
liệu nào
anh
đi rửa sửa lại bản vẽ là bàn hóa đơn
đúng không có bảng lịch trình Lịch trình
cụ thể kéo rồi lịch trình cụ thể em ạ
Ừ thì không còn hóa đơn Chi tiết nữa bảo
vé thế là phải đưa chi tiết rồi đúng
không
anh
Ừ
lại bản tiếp nha
U17 rồi làm tiếp theo nhỉ
Ừ đúng rồi kìa mã hóa đơn này mã lịch
trình sẽ là khóa chính của bảng vé vì
vàng vé bản trung gian giữa hai là kia
nhưng mà nó vẫn là thực thể là vẫn phải
báo đấy thôi
vé giường nằm
Ừ Ok em để anh trả lời nói bạn nhớ là
sửa Có bạn bảo là dưỡng xe khách Gần đây
tôi đi thì nó sẽ có cả bao gồm cả
bao nhiêu chỗ ngồi này bao nhiêu cái chỗ
giường năm này thì ông cũng sẽ phải tạo
ra lần đầu cột à không phải lên đấy mà
hai cột 1 cột là số chỗ ngồi số chỗ
giường nằm đấy xong ngồi vé thì sẽ là sẽ
là kiểu kiểu nó một kiểu có thể quy ước
kiểu là nó giường nằm hay ngồi đây chẳng
thế nếu về sau không có Và nếu vì sau xe
nó sẽ không được thay đổi là nói chuyện
giường nằm ngồi không biết về sau đó có
thêm cải tiến đi không thì nó sẽ ra chờ
thì ông phân 2 cột như thế luôn đấy và
thêm một cuộc sống hôn kiểu ở trong cái
vé sau đó về sau chú để ông sẽ đến mà
xem mặt đã đặt bao nhiêu vé dừng làm bao
nhiêu vé ngồi các Xử Nữ để thống kê ra
còn bao nhiêu chỗ trống xe tải
em còn nếu là sửa ông muốn làm biến tấu
à Bởi vì xe ông có xe chỗ này chỗ kia có
xe chỉ nằm có sai chỉ ngồi có xe thì
ngồi như vip hay gì kiểu đủ kiểu nữa thì
cái đấy là sẽ phải
I Nếu lại cụ thể kiểu ngồi của từng xe
nó tạo ra một bản riêng nữa với một xe
nó sẽ có nhiều kiểu và số chỗ của từng
kiểu đấy Sau đó thì vé của mình sẽ lại
có thêm kiểu nữa Nói chung là lằng nhằng
Ừ
ok ngắm tiếp theo nhỉ
thời
từ hôm nay có 10 bạn rồi
phải bảo vệ rồi đấy
à à
U23
ở nhà 10A nhóm 23 giờ hơi 23 trước cũng
được Ông nào chưa ạ
U23 97 -
vì vậy
đáng Trà Vinh thấy trường đào tạo chúng
ta nếu bên là Ninh Bình
Ừ
sử dụng nó khóc à
ô tô em vẫn lấy sinh viên làm thêm chìa
khóa sinh viên bạn ấy tình trạng với
Serie A
chị xem chức năng quản lý giáo viên làm
thêm chìa khóa thông tin của giáo
Anh sắp lịch học lớp học cho giáo viên
phụ khoa Với quản lý chương trình Cùng
với sắp xếp lịch học cho
cô
giáo viên là được điểm danh sinh viên
Xem lịch giảng dạy và chấm điểm cho sinh
viên anh Vinh về được xem cách học được
xây trên biển
ở
Ừ
từ đây thì em sẽ có sơ lược thể này gửi
cho anh cái link đấy đi Để anh tiện đây
mới dễ gửi gửi gửi cho anh cái link này
anh tiện Xem luôn
em luôn đồ chiếu xe mà em mà nó sinh ra
những cái gì
phải từ chức năng để ra cho thể đúng
không cái thằng thôi đúng không Đúng rồi
gửi qua gỗ mít nữa
Ê Linh Linh không Mình phân tích Qua đây
được
Ừ
Ờ
dụng ở đâu 5 đối tượng sử dụng nó ngon
có
ở Hệ giáo viên và xây dựng I
Ừ nhưng mà gồm Khoa
khóa
bộ phim sex Việt Nam Á
có một môn thuộc nhiều ngành đúng không
ở mức giá thì việc bình tĩnh Nguyễn Tĩnh
một môn thuộc nhiều ngành thì em đưa lại
mã ngành ở trong môn á
Không không cần xóa đây chứ
nhau rồi
tiết lớp có mã ngành ok rồi này lớp phải
là
mã khóa chứ nhỉ
À không không không có mã khóa trong
ngành Ok Ok đồ rồi anh đi rồi rồi sinh
viên tình trạng Ok
phòng học nữa
em có
cả phòng nữa
nó bị thừa đấy nó thành bài toán khó hơn
đấy à
quá cả
em heo cả điển này cả lịch này cả điểm
danh này rồi bây giờ còn cả phòng nữa
nhiều quá em ạ cả tấn công
nhiều đã bỏ phòng em
phải nhiều không Bây giờ ông làm hết
xong mấy cái bảng bia để tối ưu mà mất
sử 12 hàng thôi làm sao làm được những
tính năng còn lại nữa
đâu hôm sáng xong rồi
lịch
mã loại là gì nhỉ lịch có loại là cái gì
nhỉ
các khối u nữ
thời tiết bắt đầu tư kết thúc ngày mã
phạm vi một mã giảm trên 2 và có thể là
có thật hay giáo viên dạy cùng một lớp
Đúng không ngày Cùng trông thì đúng
không
Ừ đúng
Ừ
ngành thì giáo viên nó chỉ được dạy
trong cái Khoa 1khoa cố định đó
anh thấy cái nhà ngói lưu lại mã khoa rõ
hơi sai
trong những môn mà phụ khoa huyện
Anh Khoa của em là Khoa
Khoa không phải khóa đúng không Và
kinh tế đô Ok Ok anh hiểu anh nữa
nhé mình như thế thì cũng phải có khóa
chứ nhỉ đúng không
nghiệp
anh trực tiếp với bệnh nhân mã mở khóa
đâu Chứ em không hiểu em em
đúng không
có mã ngành mã khóa thôi không
và cái mã phòng học đi Này
mình có
danh sách tham dự à
gọi là ở dùng từ danh sách tham dự cũng
được mã sinh viên Mã lịch điểm danh điểm
danh ở đây cái điểm danh nó là em em bị
lưu cái điểm danh là gì nhá ạ
anh
chưa em định đi về đi
ừ ừ
nghĩa là lưu lại là cậu đi học hay là
cái gì đó đúng không ạ
ai
nghe được gì vậy em MP nè
không ạ
Okay điểm ở đây có mã môn mã sinh viên
loại điểm số điểm
loại điểm Em lưu cái gì nha
bạn để tránh việc nối đỡ bị rối như này
trình nữa cả cũng lo nhà nữa đề để tránh
các bạn bị rối loạn ý thì anh bảo rồi
chưa Nó nối được tính năng ấy thì em sẽ
dễ hiểu hơn em sẽ tạo nhiều trang này mà
kiểu đầu tiên thì gọi là những cái bảng
Bảng lúc đầu bản ban đầu và sơ khai ban
đầu thì sẽ có những bản nào khóa ngành
môn lớp sóng hồi khóa sinh viên giáo
viên thì gì đấy rồi Tiếp theo là từng
tỉnh Nam Ví dụ ở tỉnh Nam phân công thì
nó ở những cái thực thể nào đấy Đấy xong
rồi tính năng lịch lịch học hay lịch thi
gì đó liên quan đến những thực thể nào
đấy rồi tính năng điểm ấy ăn thức thể
nào đấy thì em sẽ chia nhỏ chưa nhỏ đấy
ra Các em cục chung ngay nhìn nó bị rối
em bị rối đúng không khó trình bày nữa
nhìn nó bị rối em hiểu mà mình không nhớ
được mình không Mình không bao quát được
hết đúng không
Nhìn như ma trận sau các bạn cũng như
thực thể hơn thì không biết chơi
không Không cần phải hiển thị hết một
toàn bộ thực thể trên một Trang đâu rồi
cực
lý lịch lịch học đúng không nó sẽ có
tuyết bắt đầu tiết kết thúc kia đúng
không
Nếu thế thì cái bảng lịch của em có giày
phết đấy và
này
mình sẽ phải nhập trước cái lịch đấy
nhưng mày Anh thấy em còn có bảo là
học mà
tính năng này sắp xếp lịch dạy học mà em
phải nhập trước đây Linh dạy học chứ
em Em sang lại tính năng đi
phải lưu lại trong bảng trong thực thể
lên chứ Hai chú tạo bảng riêng
Em phải nhập trước bao nhiêu ngày trước
trước đấy giờ đúng không sau đó đi đến
đến hôm đấy sinh giáo viên thì vào điểm
danh cho sinh viên thôi à
à
Thế thì có phải là cái bảng lịch sẽ rất
nhiều Trước
thì
sau phần mềm em phải làm tiện lợi cho
người dùng không phải người dùng cứ ngày
nào cũng
ngày nào lại không đến nỗi quá Nhưng mà
ví dụ ở sắp xếp chứ trước lịch 1 tháng
hả lạ đây hình dung nghe có bao nhiêu
bao nhiêu lớp
bao nhiêu môn
bao nhiêu lớp là tuần tháng sau sẽ học
ngồi sắp xếp lịch đã sử đã sắp hết trước
một tuần đi cũng cũng phải nhập tay bao
nhiêu cái rồi đúng không
em hiểu gì anh không Thì cái phần mềm
của em về sau sẽ phải làm vụ này Nếu mà
em muốn làm cho xếp lịch hả em sẽ phải
làm cho tự động kiểu dạo này em chỉ cần
nhập à à kết quả từ thứ hai đến thứ sáu
cái con và môn này Môn này thì đó lập
tức là phải được hết sẽ lấp đầy được hết
nhiều chứ còn không mày về sau em chính
em về sau anh bảo là
cho em tạo bây giờ em phải tạo lịch gần
như là cả một năm học cho tận 10 lớp tôi
phải học đủ môn
thống kê ra sinh viên nào nghỉ học nhiều
sinh viên nào không được thi Văn Vân với
em em sẽ khá khá thấy có vấn đề đấy đúng
không với việc mỗi mày Cái tính năng này
rồi
chứ
hơn thì tạm bỏ điểm đi em chỉ làm mỗi
liên quan đến lịch cho anh ạ
chị
thơ tựa đầu
đúng rồi em tạm bỏ cho anh cái điện đi
em em chị làm mỗi liên quan đến lịch và
phân công xe máy bạn được không đã rồi
về sau tính tiếp cái đấy hoàn toàn thể
vì sao phát triển sao
ok chưa
Em Trong Đêm
hôm nay cũng sửa lại rồi mà sao là phải
xem lại đây sau Ok tạm thời Thế đã
một lúc rồi mới nghe được
hôm
biết được không Mai mới đến mấy giờ đây
40 phút rồi mới có được ba nhóm
1 tận gần 20 nhóm vậy chờ trả hôm thử
nằm ai tiếp rồi chín rưỡi rồi nhỉ Chán
không cũng hộ tôi con đang bị viêm họng
là Chung sức khỏe yếu nhưng mà khan
nhiều ạ
khi đóng góp cho sinh bóng thủy tinh
lỏng Ok anh thấy cái beat kia rồi ok à
công ty có rất nhiều trong những khu vực
của mình anh mới tin mới nhất khu vực
thành thị đầu
tiên là con cá sấu dầm các thời điểm này
với nó gồm nhiều các
bác sĩ khác nhau
Muốn công kích gồm các nhiều cái cái cái
không gian khác nhau là đến thăm bác
Ok anh thấy tên nó phải tiếng Anh vậy
Chuẩn kê ô
Em về chưa ạ
chúng ta một mạch từ khi về phép tính
bảng khác của của
VTC1 loạn và là loại phân có mái che
Ơ hay
bộ phim
Đó là một trực tiếp trên đèo con em màu
xanh của gót năm học phải có là bắt đầu
mà là kết thúc vào ngày đấy thế này em
đang có một cái một cái một cái ý tưởng
nó không biết là thế nào Nó là cái một
số gì người ta hay đặt kiểu khung giờ cố
định hàng tuần thì chưa biết làm thế cực
trơ khi cái cổ nào vào đây à
ít và một cái tên trót
một đứa trẻ đặt một một cái pit100 gió
thật là một cái bưu thì sẽ có có is có
Face điểm có ít và có sai sót Mà
giá của giáo viên đấy à
anh đã cực không cái khó nhất ở đây đó
là gay nhớ cái bài toán này khói bớt khổ
cái nào nó sẽ có
đầu ngồi Đúng rồi
này như thế nào nhé Anh dùng ạ Ừ
à à
cho đến thiết kế Nói chung là thật ra
mình không cần phải hiển thị ra lại Mô
hình để mở cho
cho người tại nơi trồng chọn cốt là mình
có lần đấy sân đúng không
về bản chất là khi mà chọn cái chân to
cho não 4 cái sân nhỏ
qua giá nó khác thôi và câu
đã ta bây không thể giải quyết được vấn
đề này em vẫn phải kiểm tra bằng cốt Anh
nhớ anh như thế mà làm sao thiết kế
Lullaby làm kiểm tra được
chân to các thứ nào
chị em lương dân ở giống như vậy anh bảo
là tạo ra cả sơn to và sân nhỏ là đúng
rồi nhưng mà Thì anh à mình sẽ phải lưu
lại một cục nữa một phút nữa là ngay đi
của thằng cha của nó
là bà cụt này nó sẽ là lùn có thể lùn ra
sao
IDM em idvs cũng được này em theo biết
chưa em ơi Em đợi anh em trong các ít
hay nào trong nào ấy đấy Đúng rồi Đúng
rồi
anh đi biết cái cái này em hiểu để anh
thử nói em hình dung nhá dù ở sân nhỏ
thì bản chất là nó bốn cái chân nhỏ ở
đấy nó sẽ có ai đi Hoàng Sa là cái thằng
nào Bộ vì mua cứ đặt cây sâm nhỏ rồi sẽ
không được là hàng xa và mua khi đang
hành tra rồi Không phải làm sao nhỏ em
Em hiểu gì anh không
thằng cha luôn giờ nó sẽ không Thằng cha
nào nữa đúng không
đấy
thì thì nghĩa là mình không có tâm hàng
ấy nhưng mà mùa khi mà Đạt thằng cha thì
phải kiểm tra xem có thằng con nào không
Đã là thời chưa đứng trước và ngược lại
là đảm con thì kiểm tra xem còn cha ở bị
đau tay chưa Đúng rồi Đúng rồi hả Ừ đấy
nhé Em phải kiểm tra một cốc chứ tao ra
tao bây giờ Không giải quyết rồi em sẽ
gặp này mà
Đấy đấy cái khó nhất ấy hiểu chứ OK anh
ạ à à
Anh ở quần đảo kết quản lý thì em chia
ra là quản lý của một cái cây tiền và
quản lý của tất cả các dây điểm viên
chiên thêm cái một cái nào vở nữa
còn lý của từng fadem thì em sẽ có
anh
không tiêu tiền lý
phải có lưu lại ID cảm Another
anh
không ạ
Ừ
ơi Chắc là bây giờ tôi mới nghĩ ra đấy
Còn cái thôi của tôi Tôi làm nhớ tôi làm
điều gì nhói lắm để tôi chợt nhớ nghĩa
chả có khái niệm Thế nào là dưới chuẩn
mình mình làm thế nào để với sau mình
kiểm tra bằng cốt cho nó tiện thôi đúng
không
nhà
mình có ai đi rô này ai this problem
apeach Tại sao lại lưu lại đi từ đường
đã gì có ít nó có ID spader rồi Em xóa
cái đi sư dùng trong cái Build review u
u
cái á một bit có nhiều time clock để xem
nhé Đúng Tết tại sao có bếp nhá Anh chưa
hiểu ý em mà
là ngày nào chỉ kiểu chết tham mà chị em
mới chỉ để là gió bắt đầu phải là kết
thúc rồi còn còn em để là phải công này
chứ không phải có ngày nào mày làm chứ
không này theo hóa đơn ngày nào thì cái
Vít Lấy Chồng mở sẽ có ngay kích đó nhà
bà
Ô
mà em nói ở kia là một ít có nhiều time
slot đúng không ạ
ở cái đoạn này em bị nhầm Đúng là một ít
có nhiều tham lót nhưng mà ngược lại thế
11 timeslot cũng thể đốt Nhớ beat à và
và bình tĩnh và thực tế là cái cung dầu
này đó nó là cố định hay là như nào ấy
Anh chưa hình dung em lắm Bởi vì bởi vì
cái không Giờ em đang định để là user
đạt được cứ gọi xô đạt được thế này là
thực ra cái không Giờ này nó không cần
phải tạo ra làm gì đã nghĩa là sân lúc
thấy trống người dùng làm thôi mà
anh nghe xóa cái thằng slot đi em ạ Chị
có tham peptamen ở ngay trong cái bưu
rồi được rồi
trừ khi là em thuê là cả phải đúng khung
giờ từ 3G thì đó Và thậm chí ở cái khung
giờ Đấy nó phải đắt tiền hơn ơi gió cũng
giờ ha cả đấy thì em mới cái tạo hẳn một
bảng riêng đến cấu hình cái không Giờ
còn không thì em muốn cho là chích đến
Đạt lúc nào được miễn là sân trống
Vậy thì nó khác đúng không
Anh xóa cái timeslot đi này đúng không
Thì tham ở trong cái này đúng rồi thêm
gì thêm thánh ca mân rồi Lúc đấy
Đúng rồi Thì ý tôi thế không phải mũi
tên mà nói chung là nếu mà Mấy ông còn
cấu hình cả khung giờ nào liên quan đến
giá tiền dụ là thôi trước tôi làm là
không phải liên quân lên con giá tiền
với tôi sẽ chơi theo hệ số nhiều không
Ví dụ là đặt trong khung giờ từ
5 giờ đến 9 giờ tối hả nạ thì nó sẽ giá
nó sẽ đắt hơn nhân 1,5 lần so với giá
kiểu nhân 1,25 gì đó sau một cái giá một
tiếng và cho lúc mà thuê sân ở hạn đấy
Vân đấy còn nhưng bây giờ thì ra là mấy
ông hiểu được bài toán nhưng hệ tốt
nhưng mà Mấy ông Nếu mà chưa tìm bài hát
để làm thế thì mới ông có làm đơn giản
trước đã cốt để mà mình hình dung được
cách giải quyết các bài toán là đặt liên
quan đến khung giờ từ ra bài toán đối
oán hay nó thường nên con không Giờ mày
ông để nó rất là nhiều đúng không mình
giải quyết được cái về toàn đấy đã thành
công rồi là mình thống kê các thử là
thành công rồi nếu không cần về giải
quyết dứt điểm được hẳn cái bài toán ấy
đâu bởi giải quyết dứt điểm bài toán nó
phức tạp lắm Nó mình nhưng không cần
phải cầu kỳ nỗi chi tiết Chị chuẩn đến
thế
tạm ổn rồi có gì em nói nốt cái Moderm
với Manager đó là sao đúng không ạ
À
thế à còn còn thắc mắc gì lắm nhỉ anh
không hiểu à
Ừ ok ờ ra người đặt chân thì không cần
phải đăng ký bỏ bát Quốc chưa cần tên là
số điện thoại nữa đấy
này cũng được
nhóm nhóm Em là nhóm 10 đúng không
Nhập tiếp theo đi nghỉ ở
Ê bà nhóm
cần một tiếng rồi 3 nhóm mỗi nhóm 20
phút
Ừ nhưng mà tôi vẫn sẽ phải cổ chữa tất
cả các nhóm mấy ông đừng có kiểu à
anh
không thấy ông chủ bài nhóm cùng chung
chữ đấy mình rồi thì mình không cần gì
nữa
Nhấn 6 rồi ok nhóm 6A
ừ ừ
phần mềm quản lý lớp bổ túc thì có 5 đối
tượng rụng là học viên không thuộc khoản
tài khoản nhân viên tư vấn và dây đeo vụ
và quản lý
Thấy thằng đó Ok Ok anh thôi à
quản lý thì chủ yếu này quản lý là quản
lý hai đối tượng là nhân viên tư vấn
ngoài cho vụ
như tư vấn trước thì nhân viên tư vấn sẽ
lo cho học viên cho về tư vấn cho các
ngành học của học viên các lớp học sắp
xếp hợp kim và các lớp học
Anh Hoàng về giấc ngủ thì quản lý chủ
yếu về lớp học sẽ sắp xếp giáo viên với
lại mua về môn và lớp học
a
a a
Ừ
chắc là sẽ có những hình học khác nhau
các môn khác nhau
mỗi lớp học sẽ có nhiều môn Mỗi môn sẽ
có người đó không
à
thì sẽ có mối quan hệ kiểu là một nhân
viên tư vấn sẽ có nhiều kiêng thì một
học viên sẽ có thể để lại một bình luận
về một về nhân viên tư vấn mà mình đã
tưởng là em
hoặc như thế này ạ
anh bình tĩnh bình tĩnh mình sẽ bình
tĩnh á đề để anh hỏi hai câu thứ nhất đó
là
học viên có trước phải lớp học có dưỡng
ừ ừ
ở lớp học lớp học
có lớp học vào trước à a wi-fi i
ghi chú khi em làm theo kiểu là em không
quan tâm mà số lượng sinh viên đăng ký
cái đấy là sai nhá rất nhiều trường bây
giờ nó phải có đủ lượng sinh viên Anh
chỉ nó bắt đầu mở lớp mình nói nhầm nhé
đảo chuyện Ông mở lớp rồi cùng một hai
đứa đi dậy ông tốn tiền thuê giáo viên
không Không Ai Làm Thế đã cái hồ sơ đăng
ký có trước đủ đủ lượng đăng ký mới bắt
đầu mở đó là đứa con Tú lượng đăng ký
nhưng mà cái lớp học
đúng không thể lớp học là phải có trước
Ừ cái lộn không không không không không
không
đừng Đừng nhầm nhá Cái học viên học
trong lớp thì đương nhiên vẫn phải có mà
lớp thì đúng nhớ ra nói là cái phiếu đơn
ăn trí của học viên đó là một cái khác
đừng nhầm nhá
một thực thể mở diêm Em gộp chung nó vào
trong Học viên là em sai rồi đấy Cái thứ
nhất thì thứ hai đó là một học viên có
thể học được bao nhiêu lớp
nhiều lớp anh đưa anh đồng ý anh thích
thì anh đăng ký cả Học tiếng Trung học
là tính nhân cũng được có sao đâu có
được không
được đúng không em nhiều mà sao nó chẳng
ai chia tiền ở đúng không
thế thế thì rõ ràng là em sai đúng không
em Em hiểu đoạn nào không Ngay đoạn này
vẫn sai rồi em Em đang ôm cái này rất à
rất là đúng nhưng mà đấy là cho lớp học
bình thường chứ không phải có lớp học bổ
túc bạn ấy bị nhầm rồi Phiếu đăng ký học
có đầu tiên thì đăng ký học dựa theo mã
nhân viên tư vấn đấy sau từ phía đăng ký
học nó có thể nó có thể biến thành học
viên và học viên đấy lại sau lớp học
Nghĩa là
đấy à bây giờ không tiện ghi nhưng mà
chú hình dung cái mối quan hệ được không
Cái Hà sinh ra trước thằng nào chú hình
dung về điều này đã đúng không
phải là nhân viên tư vấn là nhân viên đi
Chuẩn ạ
sau đó thì là phiếu đăng ký học đúng
không xong rồi cho nhân viên tư vấn sẽ
vào tư vấn hàng ấy để thằng đấy Thằng
đấy đủ lượng đủ lượng đăng ký rồi sẽ mở
lớp đúng không sau đó thằng học viên sẽ
là thằng nhảy vào giấy bằng lớp học đấy
đúng không Vậy là một phải có một mình
sẽ học và lớp học đấy nó sẽ cố định luôn
môn nó không quan tâm đến ngành ở đấy
đâu em Em không cần nữa Ôm cái bên kia
không liên quan đến ngành đâu lớp học Để
cố định luôn môn lớp học vẽ học môn nào
muốn nào luôn rất đơn giản thế thôi và
nó cố định luôn đó giáo viên nó không nó
nói chung là cố định nhiều cá lắm em
không còn làm cái phân công gì cả ạ
anh vẫn là cái học là một thể luôn Đúng
rồi em đăng ký riêng đầy đăng ký học nó
khoa học đầu
đúng không ạ
Ừ lúc đấy ai cả được nó
chứ bà từng từ cái phân phía đăng ký học
đấy nó sẽ để lại bình luận Thế nên là
cái mã học viên chưa cái bình luận
chuyện Ông sai Nói chung nhà ông Toàn bộ
ở đây ông đã bị nhầm hết xanh cái của
cái chương trình đào tạo thực tế rồi
chứ không phải là chương trình của bộ
lớp bổ túc
Ừ nó xóa đi nghỉ hai em nhảy luôn hằng
sao
để sang đề tài khác
Ừ
chắc cha
em hết lòng chỉ thiếu thiếu khí học đúng
không Không nói sai tất cả là nhiều cái
sai đấy em đập đi làm lại đi không cần
nhàng không cần môn thì có thể tách A
như thế nhưng mà nó luyện nó còn luôn
lưu luôn mã môn này giống nó học rồi
chúng là chủ cần phải sửa lại này
em gửi lại đi Sau đó thì hôm sao anh
kiểm tra Anh chậm lại
Ừ đúng rồi đập đi xây lại nhanh hơn ông
ông ngay từ cái đoạn đầu mình nhầm rồi
à à
anh em vẫn không hiểu thế
đầu tiên nha là có thể có môn trước Đúng
rồi có thể có môn này để học sinh viên
nên nhìn Môn đấy trong mô tả môn nhà
đúng không ạ sau đó thì sinh viên sẽ
điền với phom đăng ký để vào đăng ký môn
đúng chứ đúng không sau đó thì nhân viên
sẽ tự sẽ nhìn thấy cái pho đăng ký cô ở
của học viên xong rồi tư vấn các thủ hư
đúng không sau đó thì khi mà giáo vụ
thấy đủ lượng fan đăng ký đủ Còn một môn
rồi bắt đầu ấn nút ấn nút thì sẽ bắt đầu
mở cả lớp mở cả lớp và ngồi tất cả những
cái phía đăng ký kia vào trong cái lớp
đấy đúng không xô ngồi chọn ngày khai
giảng mà chọn này kết thúc Vân được chứ
Đấy
ở lớp đấy nó sẽ cố định theo cái môn mà
kiểu truyền đăng ký kia đã chọn luôn
đúng chứ chứ
anh đúng không và hoàn toàn là một người
học viên có thể đăng ký được nhiều lớp
nhiều môn chính xác là nhiều nhiều môn
đấy chứ mày bởi vì lớp là chưa môn mà nó
học
Đấy xong rồi giáo viên nó sẽ đổ ốp luôn
và cụ thể dán luôn từ đầu đến cuối đi
cùng với một nốt thôi đúng viết
Mở Zalo
Ừ thế thôi không có nhà nghỉ ở đây cả
đấy em cứ làm xong hết rồi đấy bình luận
là một cái tính sao thì sao ạ
Anh ấy sửa tập đi làm lại đi em à
Nhớ đấy mấy ông phải khảo sát thực tế
vào mấy ông thảm sát thực tế cả mày cứ
nhìn đề Xong rồi ông cứ nghĩ ra rồi
mấy ông phải Thảo xác thực tế phải hình
dung được cả từ đầu đến cuối người dùng
làm những cái gì có vân vân đúng không
Thì để ông ấy hình dung được là mấy ông
phải thiết kế
chức năng như thế nào xong rồi thì cái
đối tượng như thế nào đúng không không
không thể ốp một ah tabai cho tất cả
những cái phần mềm được xuống trước
đã ta bây thì kế loạn hết cả lên thấy gì
sau không làm được đâu cái sau làm phần
mềm nó cứ bị loạn đấy cho nó nhớ em nhấn
vào cháu ạ
thế hả ngắm rồi ngọn 16 Ok em
anh em em làm về quản lý cho thuê sân
bóng
ý
thì
sơ đồ đúng mạng hay là sao cứ từ Phân
tích cách mạng đi ra các bạn nãy giờ
phải phân tích Chức năng vừa mới đến sơ
đồ đấy anh nghe hình dung bạn để làm
việc
Chúc em thì không có
khách hàng
thì gần gốc từ lần đầu đón khách hàng
với
Nguyễn Thị Quyên khách hàng thì có thể
xem xong tự đăng ký cái mà em thì mình
em tính sao rồi Có thêm tìm kiếm đặt
xong rồi xem nếu đặt xong thời gian đăng
nhập giúp quản trị viên thì quản lý hệ
thống đăng nhậpđăng xúc quý khách để lấy
xong về lấy thông tin quản lý là thì nó
đỡ ông ngoài quản lý thống kê
gà con
hồ sơ đồ thì
nó khách hàng thì có thì có nhiều khó
đơn
11 qua nó không mọc cái khu vực thì có
nhiều nhiều nhiều xong
một thể loại thì là có
thiết kế cái xanh đấy thì nó có thể
khi cái thể loại gì đã thuộc nhiên so
với lọc xăng thì nó có thể
có tiếp theo rồi đó một cái đó thì thể
loại em Em thử ví dụ thể loại gửi lại
các nghĩa là song song với vụ lỗi xăng
nem trong 7 xong cái xong mà người người
người chơi á à Thế ông đã tìm cách
có kích cỡ rồi
cũng được Đổi lại tên Nga ông đổi tên
cái hàng này không để ý
Ừ rồi à
ở đây thì ra vừa nãy có nói về cái vụ mà
vừa nãy chữa cho đúng Nhóm kia rồi đó là
cái chân to của ông nóng có thể bàn bốn
với sân bé em em muốn làm một cái ông
hay thôi bỏ khó quá mù quáng
nhiêu đó Bây giờ thì thường song toi
chắc em nghĩ chắc xong 11 mà bốn bốn cái
sân nhỏ nó ghép lại như mày không biết
là 4 cái sau đó là song song gì
quan trọng gì đâu chị là chị hay là chỉ
cần là bón xăng viết lại được không Có
buồn không phải bốn con hỏi đó em em sẽ
lưu lại mã của thằng Sơn to hàng sân nhỏ
nó sẽ lưu lại Mã Nàm sưng to để biết
được là nó là con của nó là gặp lại tạo
thành cái chỗ nào thế thôi
miếng là cái răng nhỏ là nhỏ hơn kia cái
xong tôi không Không hả miễn cái này ở
nước Anh thì anh không chơi đá bóng ông
nào Giải thích hộ ông ấy đã thương em ở
quê Nó là một cái xăng lớn là xong trong
7 đó rồi bé xanh em còn cái xong này thì
em muốn biết tại vì vậy em có đá bóng
xong 11 là để biết là cái cái son này có
sao nên làm như không thấy hình dung
được
bao nhiêu
em thôi mùa xuân bằng Bosch được cái anh
anh gửi anh không có tâm nữa đấy quan
tâm việc à thưa các bạn đang bị là đôi
khi là các bạn đúng là biết bài toán
thực tế như nào các bạn muốn giải quyết
về ta đấy Ghi nhận nhưng mà các bạn còn
còn thận con vướng nhiều cái đừng có tạo
khó mình tạo dễ thôi Bảo là đối với em
anh băng qua sân nhỏ thôi em không có
tâm 4 phân gì cả cũng được mà có sao đâu
ông phải đem cái này đem bán cho ai đâu
mà ông phải sợ sai
thằng đó
ấy thì anh bảo rồi Chỉ cần lưu lại mã
của sân Tân ở trong bản thân em thêm một
cột là cột mã sân nữa em sẽ biết được và
là cái nó nó là thằng con Thảo
quản lý không Giờ anh thấy không cờ đâu
nhỉ
Nhưng mà em tạo hình cái thời nghe em
hát cũng không biết em cứ đặt tại người
Là khi màn đặt xong làm người dùng nhập
phải nhập thời gian bao nhiêu tiếng nữa
nên là em cứ em cứ ghi tham thăm nhạc
kết thúc chị xem này chắc quản lý là
chắc truy vấn
cơ sở dữ liệu qua đi
Ừ đúng rồi thì mình lưu lại thời gian
thế thôi thì nó thư gan đấy thế không
không được gọi là khung giờ nói chuyện
gọi là giờ bắt đầu và kết thúc thôi nó
không giờ nó một cái khung cố định nó
khác - biết
không Giờ đâu cũng giờ lằng nhằng lắm
không Tôi là kẹo từ 1 giờ bao giờ bao
tiền cái gì nữa không biết cái vậy giải
quyết sao thằng chiều có cho có hình
chung với cái
mình xử lý cái đấy sao hết thì mình sẽ
là tạm một cái thực thể riêng thực thể
không rầu nồi em cái hóa đơn thôi
Cái này tắt tất nhiên là
anh ấy nghĩa là làm đơn giản trước em ạ
cứ cứ phức tạp làm gì vội Tao làm đúng
được đó là nghe nữa Ở đây mình sẽ có là
bảng hóa đơn mình sẽ có thời gian tạo
này Tao tới trạng thái này không ông
không có già
có tổng giá đấy chứ đúng không là anh
bay rồi
không giá về sau sân thay đổi ông đơn
ông thay đổi giá theo ạ
toán Con kiểm toán Chứ không
bây giờ đợi giá sơn đông người sau thay
đổi toàn bộ đơn cũ của ông thay đổi theo
cái giá sâm thì chết à đúng không
ê
thôi
ca nhạc em Em còn
muốn phát triển amry2 muốn hỏi thêm
nhiều
ở hiện tại không biết nữa nhưng mà nếu
mà có phát triển chắc cái gì mà không
biết chắc em
ở nhà mình tĩnh cái sân hỏi lưu lại ID
của Tân đã để biết được sân này có
lưu lại ID của sân lớn để biết được là
sân lớn đã đặt được đấy chưa Nếu không
được đặt rồi thì Xuân nhỏ sẽ có một đạp
và ngược lại đó là kiểu Nếu mà
sao lớn đặt rồi thì sẽ nhỏ không đưa đạt
đến nhỏ lắm rồi sân đối ngay người bạn
ấy em thấy cái chữ A cho nhớ bên kia là
đã luôn đó chỉ biết thế thôi ID peace võ
vào
đây đó mà không thêm một cột nữa lại đi
biết
khi sex
à à
nude nổi lên đúng rồi đúng rồi đúng
không Nghĩa là nghĩa làm chuyện là có
những con trai cả thì bản chất là nó là
cha rồi thì nó rất lớn đấy thì nó sẽ
không Không cần phải nối về thằng nào cả
sân con thì nó sẽ ngồi làm cha thì biết
được à Tao là kiểu thích ghi ID pic 3
lần rõ nghĩa là được hiểu đã như kiểu
dạng mà mình nối Hoàn trà mình biết được
thằng cha là bà thấy chưa có dạy thằng
cha nó sẽ kiểm tra xem có những thằng
con nào nó đến nó đã được đã tan chưa
thì để mà mình mình cho đặt cái sân đấy
Hiểu không
ừ ừ
Ừ ok Chắc thế thôi nhỉ à
Anh đọc tiếp theo nhỉ à
hôm nay vắng này Hôm nay tôi thấy đông
hơn mà tiếp theo nhóm 13 Ok em ạ
vợ phải màn hình chưa
Rồi em ạ
Á Đông
ở
đối tượng sử dụng là có tất niên gia bộ
giáo viên và sinh viên về chức năng quát
Minh là quản lý trong cấp 3 dư sinopec
cuộc cho cháu vụ giáo viên và sinh viên
gió bộ là quản lý tài khóa nhàng lớp cho
tới phân công về và nhóm tiệm chỉ là mà
phân công dạy học và quản lý chiến tranh
trước sau khi có yêu hết rồi mới làm hai
cái này
Ok Ok về cùng đi lên gặp giáo viên thì
sẽ đang chọc Xem xin lập Dạ điểm danh và
xem kết quả thống kê
sinh viên rồi cũng chi cũng tương tự như
giáo viên
Thành ơi cứ bình tĩnh quay quay quay
quay lên trên gập
cho anh Nghĩa ở tạm xóa cái điểm em ạ
bây giờ em là biệt danh tôi với sao em
chỉ cần thống kê Xem sinh viên được phép
thi hay không với tạm lịch thi sẽ quá đổ
nó tạm tạm xóa điểm em ạ Cái điểm ạ sau
đội khi nào mà bảo vệ đồ án xong mấy ông
thích sự phát triển thêm thì mày không
tự phát hiện còn bây giờ tôi tôi chấm
bây giờ à về tháng năm có ý nghĩa tôi sẽ
cho mấy ông bảo vệ Tầm tháng 9 cứ cho
hẳn gọi là 4 tháng không đúng rồi thì ba
tháng nữa thôi bà hàng nữa thì mấy ông
làm được hết dùng ai không đã nhờ
rồi trình bày xong cho thể không ạ ạ
những cái bằng thực hiện phát minh giáo
vụ giáo viên
11 ngành thì có thể có chứa nhiều môn
học và một môn nào cũng có thể thuộc
nhiều ngành một mèo thì nó sẽ có bao gồm
à nhưng phần
Ví dụ như môn lập trình Window thì nó sẽ
có lập trình Windows một là tên Nguyễn
đau một gặp trên Windows hay hoa văn ở
đây chỗ học còn em có mấy ca và lấy vòng
ngày bắt đầu và ngày kết thúc để mơ tạo
cái thời khóa biểu
ông đâu ngày học phần không nhỉ
ha cũng sẽ Khoảng đầu lâu rồi
quản lý học với
anh thấy ghi mỗi ngắn gọn Thế hóa ra là
xinh làm ngay chị sẽ ra đâu rồi Ở đây
học phần này mã học phần
để anh hình dung này anh nhanh không hợp
đại học chính quy Thông cảm anh vẫn cái
này giống kiểu nó học phần là một môn nó
có nhiều hợp phần đúng không Ok rồi khóa
này
loại học phần loại học phần này là cái
gì nhỉ đến như là lý thuyết rằng
lý thuyết thực hành ok ok a hãy sao phải
lưu lại ca mấy cái trong này làm gì nhỉ
in-lieu Lại k phải là ngày bắt đầu bằng
Hiếu ngày bắt đầu ngay kết thúc là một
môn là một tầng rằng một buổi và ca phèo
nữa in tấn làm cái từ có hiểu giống
Trường Yên
Định làm kiểu thuở biểu của ngày đúng
không ạ
Ừ Anh hiểu anh quay qua quay lại đi để
lộ hết thông tin rồi
Ok
giờ à
mày Thực ra là nó là sự ước lượng rồi
Anh Nghĩa nó không đúng lắm
giống như là từ 10 có một cam sinh viên
để chồng lỡ sinh viên có đăng ký học
phần thì sử dụng nó để xóa một phần Nếu
mà không đổ lỗi
ha em nói nó lại mà
giả sử Nếu như trên
thì mất tiền không phát triển thêm cái
vụ mà thích
anh em muốn đăng ký học phần nó đánh quá
xóa
đi cái gì xóa cơ
cả
các bạn nghe thấy ông ấy nói gì không
các anh
ăn của từ từng đi
mạnh chủ của con đây rồi
nhưng mà ở lại trường em
không
nên dễ dàng kết nối lại mạng đã alo alo
cho nó mạnh là mạng yếu rồi
xe
Ok
nhiều kiến thức mới nghỉ thôi Thông cảm
tôi không học lại thích quy Tôi học
đi sẽ bị trượt Đại Học
bạn đấy nó hơi lằng nhằng
alo ngày đang ăn đi không ạ đưa có vẻ ổn
định rồi mà lại mà học phần giá cả anh
xem mà K phòng này bắt đầu mày kết thúc
anh theo cả ngày bắt đầu để anh thấy à
khẳng định được
cho đấy số buổi em ạ Anh không tin là
ngày kết thúc nó đúng đúng hạn được
ghép từ lớp khác có trường hợp đấy Ở đây
thì ra bạn đấy cũng có lưu lại mã lớp
Không nên thích thì ghép ở lớp khác
thoải mái cứ giáo Huyện sinh viên đăng
ký
bạn hết cả lên học phần là được mà
bạn ấy hình như lại mất mạng rồi
thế Làm vụ à
các bạn để làm thế là làm của thời khóa
biểu thời khóa biểu mới cái lên học à
có thời khóa biểu với cái lịch học Thực
ra nó cũng nặng đấy
thêm điểm điểm danh
ừ ừ
anh không
ở bên em thì cố định ngày bắt đầu ngày
kết thúc này ạ Có trường hợp kiểu quá
nhanh kết đúng không
ở nhà không nói chỉ cố định luôn anh
mình tính được ngày tiếp theo mình chưa
Cạn bể lên đó là anh đi làm thời khóa
biểu diễn vậy
anh nghĩa này tha thứ phải có thứ gì nhỉ
Ca là như thế nào nghĩa này nào học à
không ạ
anh khóc là một con nhắn là ký hiệu có 1
môn một môn học có một buổi hả
Ừ thế ông lưu lại ông học vào thứ mấy
kiểu gì
thì chưa Bảo nghe thì mình sẽ có hàm để
mình đổ ra tới đâu mà có nhưng mà không
có đứa làm thế Cả tính tình làm thế thì
ai hiểu được cái đào tạo bởi không
hiểu được đi sau người ta nhìn nó cái
tao bậy đâu mày đã hiểu được nghe chẳng
hiểu gì
ở đây ra ngoài việc thích thì bây giờ
sai em đang bị một nơ nó bị loạn học
phần này thì kêu tách nhỏ hơn hợp phần
Chi tiết nữa đó là cái buổi từng buổi
đấy sẽ điểm danh hơn những cái bụi đấy
nó mới chuẩn sẽ cái cái học phần này nó
phải có số ca số buổi đấy nhớ đúng không
Lúc bài này ngày bắt đầu ý đúng giờ tao
ra không ông khi kết thúc mà phải rẽ
theo số buổi để biết được à Tổng cộng
một cần phải học bao nhiêu buổi sợ nhỡ
đâu hôm đấy có việc gì dịch chẳng hạn
thì gì đó tự nhiên phải nghỉ chị rõ là
không thể cứ đúng thứ được mà phải sẽ sẽ
lấp đầy vào một cái buổi nào nó khác học
bù không
hiểu
ý anh không phải cẩn như thì ông có vài
bắt đầu ok rồi này kết thúc là đi này nó
sẽ có học phần chi tiết
đấy họ cần chi tiết nó sẽ lưu lại bản
chất là nó lưu lại
ngày ngày học đấy và mã học phần
đấy chứ không
video sau em ạ ấy tiếp nữa đấy thì thì
Phòng này thì ảnh Ok em thích cái giải
phòng cũng được rồi giới hạn vừa rồi anh
hỏi nó là giới hạn à em tìm ở lớp đúng
không ạ
em heo giới hạn học học viên đăng ký
nắm bắt đầu năm kết thúc lớp viên
của tôi muốn đâu ưu
điểm danh phổ thông ở lại món này
[âm nhạc]
họ cần có điện ngày này đúng không thể
ngay
ở cái ngày không có thực không phải là
ngày mỗi thứ cả ngày nữa đúng không mà
chết à nó sẽ có mạng xuống gần như nó
một cái buổi điểm danh đúng không Nó là
ngay với kết hợp với mã học phần sẽ biết
được đúng không sau đó thì giáo viên rồi
thế
không có bất công ạ Hôm nay Thảo Viên
điểm danh hôm nay Hùng phát vào viên đẹp
zai à là viên nào điểm danh được
chưa đúng không em nói đã quên chưa ghi
rõ trong học bằng những nỗi vẫn nói với
dòng tình ca tặng dẫn ra tay lập trong
đó còn có mã giáo viên luôn Đúng rồi thì
ghi vào ở quê à
thường là sẽ có một giáo viên phụ trách
phụ trách kể cái học tuần ấy tôi tôi
hình dung này như thế phải có một giáo
viên phụ trách tới cuối một cái chương
trình học mà nó chứ không thể để hôm nay
giáo viên này không có thêm vào dậy hôm
sau giáo viên thường em và dậy đúng
không
điểm danh rồi ok Rồi cái Vespa của em là
gì
khi ra giống nhau học phần thôi không
thế thôi Cái tinh tình tính không Tôi
nghĩ ông xong vào phần Tôi thấy ra cái
Open ông nó hơi khoai đấy
đó sẽ giống như là cái bạn kia vừa nãy
nói tạo cái không
khóa biểu trước đấy của ông đúng hay thế
thực
hiện nghe tạo xong thường có biểu trước
sau đó thì
giáo viên vào điểm danh đúng không hiểu
cứ thế
tế thì hỏi thì hỏi sau nhé
Xin cảm ơn ạ
với mấy ông thì à Hồi mà tôi dậy đồ án ở
trên lớp thực tế
hồi đồ ăn hay này đón bột thì tôi chữa
cho cả lớp được không được ăn hay mỗi
ông một kiểu như này thì chắc là tôi sẽ
phải tốn khá nhờ ra để ngồi inbox cho
từng ông một cái chữ từng ông
đấy thậm chí có nhiều nhóm mang tiếng là
để tải gần nhau Nhưng mà ừ nếu thế thì
chắc là
tôi Thực ra tôi không định livestream ở
trên
YouTube liên tục như thế này chữa cho
tưởng ông đâu cần cân nhắc xem đã
Ôi nghĩ là tôi sẽ
à có livestream livestream trên nhóm bit
caught cho đỡ rát
thôi mấy xong rồi tôi sẽ quay hệ video
gì đó thì như cái thằng Google này có
khỏe không
rồi tôi sẽ sẽ mở đi con lên Xong rồi
livestream trong cái kênh đấy cái chat
rồi ông xong rồi tôi sẽ thông báo là hôm
nay sẽ chữa cho đề tài là để tải gì đấy
Xong rồi mấy ông vào mấy ông hỏi cứ thế
được đúng không
ký tự xem lại với nhau chứ bây giờ
chiều gì về sau mấy ông sẽ cần phải hỏi
cả cốt cả lê quan có từ câu chính vấn
cho cốc là thứ cốt sao xử lý bài toán ấy
vân vân vân cũng mệt đấy chứ Bây giờ tôi
tạo gần đấy Cái video lần này buổi ở
trên YouTube nó hơi bị loãng không
sẽ đi cốt là các nhóm các bạn làm đồ án
thì bắt buộc mấy ông phải theo dõi trên
đấy chứ không thể gọi là việc sự quan
tâm đó
nhiều cái phần mềm có tích hợp sẵn
PS này nọ thích hợp quan hệ video mà
Nhưng ý mình gà không không
không còn lại livestream trên YouTube
như này có anh yêu em chị đã bị lắm
chạy cân nhắc sau
vào mỗi nghe Trúng gió
ngầm tiếp theo nhỉ à
anh em nhập 20
ok 20 sao của mỗi nhóm em nhỏ còn nhỏ mà
đường Hoàng Thắng thì chưa Rồi mẹ đúng
không anh Tài vừa xong nhóm mà 21 của
lớp phó gì đó
sóc sức khỏe không được mình sử dụng là
quản trị viên bác sĩ và khách hàng
chức năng tay của đối tượng quản trị
viên sẽ quản lý thông tin khách hàng
quản lý thông tin bác sĩ Lập Đồng viện
Vật lý đặc điểm lịch hạn cấp quyền
bác sĩ sẽ là xem được làm việc và lỡ hẹn
với khách hàng
khách hàng sẽ chỉnh sửa thông tin cá
nhân tìm kiếm bác sĩ đặt hẹn Xem thực
hành và đánh giá sau khi khám
đi xe cẩu admin
truyền hình của bác sĩ
bác sĩ và không gian khám
khách hàng là hẹn vàng
mà đánh giá
lại bên kia thế
ngày Phân tích phân tích này đã xong rồi
ô cơ bản nữa hiểu ok Tĩnh ở đây có 3 đối
tượng này rồi lịch làm việc này
việc đấy rồi Đặt lịch Ok Cũng trị cơ bản
thôi thôi quay lại biết được thể đi
tiền thì
chuẩn là giống như em vừa làm thì phải
có lịch làm việc trước thì làm việc của
em ca
nhạc
khám của mình hay là nó quy ước chung
rồi cho một người tạo ra cái đấy rồi bác
sĩ thì chắc nhận thôi
kể Bác sĩ nói chung hợp làn da bị động
trong trường hợp này đúng không Ok
amin sẽ người tạo nãy tao thôi chứ Nó
Đặt lịch khám
bác sĩ
Mai đi với tao mày đi rồi còn đắp từ đây
đi rồi em bỏ tao từ đây đi ở trong nhà
ấp con mình đi
em
nên
xe người đặt khác với người khám à
à
Đúng là nó khác nhưng mà bệnh viện vẫn
sẽ lưu lại nó sẽ tạo một bộ sơ riêng cho
bệnh nhân để lưu lại hồ sơ bệnh nhân
Bệnh viện nào thế nhưng mà bản chất là
nếu thế em phải đây có là Custom mờ ID ở
đây là tôi sẽ mở idea người cái người
đạt đấy và một cái là Bệnh nhân pace này
đi Hãy gì anh ấy vẫn phải tạo ra hay là
ai
cho ông
thể anh không có đăng nhập đặt Đạt mấy
cái này thì ra người ta không Không cần
phải đăng nhập gì cả nó lưu lại những
cái thông tin người dùng đã thử thứ Bởi
vì bởi vì là em thì em có Station ID thì
nỡ là nó đâu có email về passcode gì đâu
đúng không
Email thì ra cũng được có thể cho vào
nghĩa về sau mình gửi kết quả của cả đấy
được là sự thế mà thông báo gì chỉ đó
vào đấy
rồi tương đồng như thế
mà từ cái việc anh vừa bảo thì khám xong
người ta lưu lại hồ sơ bệnh nhân đúng
không Thì nó lại hồ sơ
hồ sơ đâu
mình sẽ tăng thêm một tập thể mà
để anh tìm xem nha một lần khám của
Lương khám của em sẽ khám như nào khám
kiểu khám bình thường hay ạ Họ sẽ nghiệm
thêm cái gì không
khi sử dụng thêm dịch vụ di động
có thuốc gì không ạ
hãy Tuấn nắp một cái đấy ạ
Còn nếu không thì à Nếu mà muốn làm ở
đơn giản này thì em cứ xóa hết đầu tiên
là xóa hết mấy cái face ẩn các từ thứ ở
trong con mình đi đúng không Thứ hai là
em có visa à bây giờ lý do không Em gộp
chung nó trong
mô tả và đánh giá thế thôi Chỉ có một
cột mô tả một cụ đánh giá hết
sau đó thì về sau khi mà bệnh nhân quay
lại khám lần lưỡi thì mình sẽ lại mình
sẽ lấy lại thông tin theo paysan ID để
mà xa được toàn bộ là lịch sự khám
chứ nó cũng không sinh ra một cái hồ sơ
thì nó nữa Mình sẽ lưu lại luôn luôn
trong clip Ám Hiệu với anh ấy
mô tả đúng không mô tả với cái
đánh giá
review review hơi thôi
comment đi một cái quy trình làm cái của
Mandy
tả của bệnh nhân lúc đầu triệu chứng
hiểu cái đấy
Tại sao lại mô tả qua thường người ta có
một cái form đăng ký là sẽ điền Ở Đây là
mô tả qua tình trạng bệnh của bạn hiện
tại để lý do bạn đi khám đúng không Đấy
mô tả của bệnh nhân là như thế Tại sao
nó thì nhưng mà bác sĩ sẽ không viết sửa
vào trong mô tả đúng không bác sĩ sẽ ghi
là sau buổi sáng mày thì kết luận là gì
không ạ
hay là để lâu địa chỉ của phòng khám
địa chỉ phòng khám à
Không dám xóa đi cái này là cho tư nhân
đi cho một phòng khám đi Đỡ dễ
Lumpur member thường này nó gắn liền với
bác sĩ rồi
em làm đi khám cái kiểu ngay khám này
xăm kiểu tư nhân là chỉ có vai bác sĩ
rồi nó cố định một phòng rồi
feedback đánh giá đúng không
ừ ừ
à à
Em học tốt là cái gì nhỉ à
Ừ ừ
này có thể lưu lại luôn trong mà đi khám
đi
anh vào cột status nữa cũng ở trong đi
khám luôn phải chắc gì nữa đến
review gì đó phim mát luôn cho người ấy
giản thế em ạ ạ
ra khủng giá này luôn đúng không Giờ đấy
mất nói không Giờ em ạ
em nhỉ
thế Không phải vừa dựa theo bảo mới khám
em biết được
tốt không anh Nghĩa không Nó cố định
nghỉ
xóa đi em ạ Có cái
mới thế mình sẽ có những cái đấy giá
trong cái lịch khám về
cái này cho chồng mẹ đơn giản đúng không
Không đơn giản hơn rồi đúng không ạ
Có
ai như thế này Chỗ nào rồi Thôi về sau
mình làm mình có đặt được các thứ thôi
chị ra
bác sĩ nào bác sĩ hot nhất hãy trả nợ
thế để cho ta không Giờ này còn những
bác sĩ nào sống còn về sau con còn theo
chuyên khoa nữa mà lại chọn chuyên khoa
có thử thử thì ra bác sĩ nào nó phải roi
4 mảnh đấy Em thấy không để biết được ca
sĩ nào trống trong việc không vỡ cũng
trưng Kha đấy và cùng khung giờ nào đó
là cho bốn mạng cũng làng nhàng ấy
Ừ thế nhỉ đẹp ok chưa em đâu
tôi kèm tiếng Anh hơn
từ nói chuyện này chịu
con con nhóm là nó không nhỉ Mấy Nhóm
kia đợi bố sau ạ
chị thôi cũng được Mày cho tôi nghĩ sớm
tí hai ngày liên tiếp hả vọng rồi
cả tôi định của mày nói chung mấy bữa
mày cũng chưa trả lời câu hỏi tâm sự gì
cả Bây giờ để buổi hôm sau đi
với thứ Năm nha mấy năm mình sẽ Chữa nốt
Ừ đấy thì mày Ông thấy à có nhiều nhóm
có thể cùng chung đề tài như cả ra cũng
cũng thứ nhất là cần các bạn nói lên
tiếng nữa
nói qua các thử thứ mà hiểu được luồng
các từ từ đã nào là con thắc mắc thì
inbox tôi Này nhá Tôi sẽ con để trả lời
em mấy ông